Of course, this one here is correct.
So if we say we want to find out if a graph has a vertex cover of size 10,
then all we need is polynomial time
because then this decision problem can be solved
in O of 2.4 to the power of 10 times N cubes time,
and the exponential factor here is no longer dependent on the input size.
So for a fixed value of K,
vertex cover can indeed be solved in polynomial time.
Of course, the running time is not independent of the size of the input graph
because you still have this polynomial factor here.
Does this statement here mean that actually P=NP?
Unfortunately, it doesn't because K can take any value,
so K can also depend on N in the general case,
but what it does mean is that
if we consider any fixed value of K,
then vertex cover becomes easy.
In other words, small vertex covers are easy to find.